do you know what a jell-o shot is a
jello shot yeah is it like some kind of
injection we are here at the Golden
Globes red carpet and we're gonna play
jello or jello shot I also want to see
how they eat jello are they the finger
people or the tongue people I'm at Unger
obviously tonight's the biggest party in
Hollywood no party is complete without
jello shot okay okay
jello so no although but some of it has
booze in it oh really
I want you to pick one for you and one
for me that one's yours okay and that
one's mine this is jello and that's a
shot great do we have to take four oh
Emily jello not this one for you do you
have any strategies and taking jello
shots no usually I take them off
people's tits but I guess tonight I'm
doing it on my own the best strategy is
to loosen it up with your finger because
it's gonna be hard to suck out of it
yeah let's throw some on top already
it's on that jello ah there we go
what is that moonshine Tommy's blood
will be alcohol whoa
you just tongued that jello sir there we
go
what are your thoughts Jenna oh that no
I'll go don't mind no booze thanks for
nothing
oh that's just straight of Julia that's
a shot
all in one call it got it disgusting I
thought the moisture would be the liquor
I thought that my science grade third
grade science craze halfway through this
red carpet and I had a lot of jello
shots
this is Hollywood's biggest party yeah
yeah you caught you did an okay job much
better with my mouth than this whoa I
just feel so bad for you I feel good I
feel so good for me
one less thing are there any confessions
you can make anything weird you've ever
done before a red carpet yeah this
morning I shaved my pubes I wanted to
feel special is that all nothing else no
now what do you want to talk about Oh
how's your day going it's great yes
let's hope it gets better
this guy is following me around and I
don't know he's stalking who he is here
it's it's just
you know it's no longer pump and it gets
personal that's what I don't like
horse it gets personal I don't know what
his name is interview right now oh is
that what you call it the hell is going
on